we've developed a system that allows
people to look at another individual and
see physiological responses of that
person so it's data they wouldn't
normally be able to see but it's
superimposed onto that other person so
they can actually see their heart
beating they can see changes in stress
based on heart rate variability and
that's all sensed remotely but you're
giving the individual a new sensory
channel that they can leverage you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen using one of the most
intriguing areas of machine learning
research is affective computing where
scientists are working to bridge the gap
between human emotions and computers it
is here at the intersection of
psychology and computer science that we
find dr. Daniel Macduff who has been
designing systems
from hardware to algorithms the consents
human behavior and respond to human
emotions today dr. Macduff talks about
why we need computers to understand us
outlines the pros and cons of designing
emotionally sentient agents explains the
technology behind cardio lends a pair of
augmented reality glasses that can take
your heart rate by looking at your face
and addresses the challenges of
maintaining trust and privacy when we're
surrounded by devices that want to know
not just what we're doing but how we're
feeling that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Daniel Macduff welcome to the show today
great to have you with us with you so
you're in human-computer interaction or
HCI and you situate your research at the
intersection of computer science and
psychology so tell us in broad strokes
about HCI and what you do so the crux of
what I do is teaching machines to
understand people in a deeper way and
that involves capturing and responding
to their emotional state so can we
design a machine that really understands
people not just what they're saying how
they're saying how they're behaving and
I think that's really fundamental to
human computer interaction because so
much of what we do as people is
nonverbal it's not described in language
and a lot of computer systems don't
understand that and that's a focus my
work is bringing that EQ to technology
EQ meaning emotional quotient yeah
that's a somewhat slang term and it's
used frequently to contrast IQ which is
something that technology has a lot of
technology can answer lots of questions
very quickly because it has access to
all of the information on the internet
but not much technology has EQ no does
any I think we're starting to see the
beginning of this so you see social
robots as a great example of systems
which have some kind of personality they
can express visually some basic facial
expressions on a screen or using sounds
or lights movies are a great example so
r2d2 is a great example of a system
doesn't have a face but can still
communicate emotions although that's
fictional we are starting to see systems
in the real world that kind of behave in
a somewhat similar way that's
fascinating I even think of wallace and
gromit animation where Gromit only
communicates with his eyes and his
eyebrows and yet you get almost
everything that he wants to say exactly
and we take a lot of inspiration from
animations and animators because I study
facial expressions it's magic or how
some creators can show so much rich
emotion just through a facial expression
and as we design systems that recognize
those and exhibit them there's a lot we
can learn from that side of the world
I'm intrigued by the field of affective
computing and I understand it aims to
bridge the gap between human emotions
and computational technologies so what
is affective computing what is it
promise and what do we need computers to
understand us as human beings for at a
high level affective computing is
designing systems that can read
interpret and respond to human emotion
and that sounds like a daunting task
there's a lot more we need to do in
research but we're starting to see
real-world systems where this is true so
systems where they can read facial
expressions for instance or understand
the voice tone of someone or look at
sentiment for instance on Facebook posts
or Twitter to understand the emotions
that are being expressed and this is
kind of where the world is now but in
the future we can imagine systems that
use multimodal data robotic systems that
interact with us in an embodied way that
also sense this type of information and
that's kind of the target we're focused
on so why do you think we need computers
to understand us I think it's
fundamental to how we interact as human
beings and so when we interact with the
system it doesn't do those things that
we take for granted it can be
off-putting for instance if a system
doesn't realize that I'm getting
frustrated with it it can be more
frustrating it can even be upsetting
there's research showing that robots
that can apologize are likes a lot more
than robots that don't even if they're
no better at completing the tasks they
were intending to complete so it can
really improve our relationship and our
well-being because it fundamentally
improves the interaction we have with
the devices around us so you co-authored
an article called designing emotion
sentient agents and aside from the
Hollywood connotations that phrase
brings to mind what should we understand
about this research Daniel and what
should we be excited about or concerned
about I think there's a lot to be
excited about in home care in healthcare
in understanding just human interaction
even more if we can design systems to
mimic some of those things it will
deepen our understanding of how we as
humans behave there are a number of
challenges that we need to overcome one
is how do we sense this information when
sensors can be intrusive
you know devices that are around us that
are listening for commands all the time
are starting to appear and you can
imagine in future there could be camera
systems as well so we need to think
about the social norms that exist around
the sensing side of things where it's is
that data go how is it stored how do we
know that the sensors on how do we
control it how do we stop it from
recording when we want to and then how
do we allow other people who are in our
lives to not be sensed even if we're
being sensed or if I invite someone into
my home and I've got a device that's
always listening or always watching what
does that mean for our social
interaction so I think there's some
challenges to overcome there but there's
also more philosophical challenges about
how much do we teach computers of human
emotion is it possible for a machine
ever to feel emotion what does that mean
and how should machines express emotion
or respond to this information we
definitely don't want to design systems
that are manipulative or that make
people feel like they're more
intelligent than they are if someone
sees a system that appears emotional
they might think wow this is really
really intelligent even if it's only
expressing very basic behaviors and that
can be challenging because some of the
other abilities of that system might be
quite weak and so people might trust it
even if it can't actually perform
accurately the tasks is trying to do
you're using terms that are interesting
and interesting is a kind of placeholder
word for other words that I'm actually
thinking like sentient
and understanding regarding a machine
and I wonder how I should interpret that
what are people like you and your
colleagues really believe about what you
just addressed can a machine ever feel
can it really understand can it become
sentient
I think machines are fundamentally
different to humans machines can
recognize some expressions of emotion
they can respond to them but I don't
think that that constitutes feeling and
emotion feeling an emotion requires
experience it requires a reward and a
cost associated with different actions
it's much much more complex than that so
I don't think machines will ever
experience emotion in the way that we do
but they will have many of the sort of
fundamental skills that we have what can
you tell us about the emerging field of
what I would call artificial emotional
intelligence or emotional technology you
use an example of a bathroom here that
has ambient intelligence and can tell
whether I've slept well why do I need
that that's a good question I think it's
important that we design systems that
are ultimately beneficial to people and
one of the roadblocks especially in
healthcare is that there's so much rich
data out there but it's very hard to
understand it or it's cumbersome to
monitor it and so designing systems that
make it seamless to be able to collect
and understand that type of data is
really important so that MIT when I was
a graduate student we built a mirror
that had a camera embedded in it was
actually hidden behind to a glass so all
it looked like was just a regular mirror
but when you looked in the mirror the
camera was using some remote sensing
technology we built to measure the
heartrate of the person and we can also
measure things like heart rate
variability which is correlated with
stress and so the mirror could then
display that information back to the
so it's not just reflecting their
outward appearance but they're sort of
in a physiological state as well and I
found that really compelling because in
many cases we want to know that
information but we might not want to
strap on a sensor or have to go out of
our way to collect it and if it can be
digitally captured by the devices we
already use there's something quite
compelling about that let's talk about
the technical aspects of your work for a
bit much of its centered on computer
vision technologies and involves webcams
and algorithms that aim to understand
emotional states
what's the field of computer vision
founded on technically and what new
developments are we seeing so computer
vision is exploding as you know the past
10 years have been some of the most
exciting in this domain with the
invention of what's commonly called deep
learning and so this is the ability to
leverage huge amounts of data to train
systems that are much more accurate than
previous system to work so for instance
we have object recognition text
recognition scene understanding that's
way more accurate than it used to be
because we have these systems that
capture lots of complex Caeser
the data and because there's so much
data that can learn from they get a
really good representation and
understanding facial expressions has
also benefited from the advances in this
technology as has a lot of other areas
of effective computing whether it's
speech recognition or understanding
vocal prosody and things like that so
there's a lot of advances that have
happened that basically improved the
underlying sensing and I don't think up
until this point we've really had the
volume of data about emotions to go to
the next level where we can really
understand okay how do we build a system
actually knows what to do with these
sensor inputs with something that's as a
more versus emotion isn't hard to define
so the basis of what you're doing is on
deep neural networks and machine
learning models that you're then
applying to the affective domain exactly
yeah so we use deep learning for
almost all of the sensing modalities we
use whether it's vision based or audio
based or language based and then that
feeds into a system which is taking sort
of intermediate level information for
instance does my facial expression
appear positive or negative is my voice
tone high energy or low energy is the
language I'm using hostile or serene and
then those intermediate states feed into
a higher level understanding which is
combined with context so we need to know
what's happening to interpret emotion we
can't just observe the person we need to
know the situation the social context
and so that's kind of where we're moving
is really to combine these sensor
observations with more contextual
information so I wasn't gonna ask you
this it wasn't on my list but how do you
gather data on emotions do you have to
bring people in and make them angry I
mean it's a serious question and a funny
way in the past that was how it was
often done but a lot of my work in the
last few years has been focusing on in
situ large-scale data collection so we
always ask people if they want to opt in
and if they do then we enable them to
use a system which is part of their
everyday life so this might be a system
that runs on their computer or ons on
their cell phone and collects this data
over time often we might prompt them
throughout the day so how are you
feeling or we might say you know it's
this feeling that we think you're
feeling correct in order to get some
kind of ground truth but ultimately we
want to be able to collect real-life
data about people with emotional
experiences because we know if they come
to a lab it's not exactly the same as
how it would be in the real world one of
the applications of this emotional
technology is the workplace in an MIT
Sloan management review article that
claims that emotion sensing technologies
could help employees make better
decisions improve concentration
alleviate stress so tell us how this
works and give us some examples of what
it looks like and then maybe tell me why
I would want my boss to monitor my eye
movements my facial
Russians and my skin conductance so one
example we give in that article is about
a trader in Japan who unfortunately
swapped the number of shares they were
selling and the price of the shares and
got those two numbers the wrong way
round and that ended up being a huge
financial loss and in high-stress
situations that can be really
problematic another example would be air
traffic control a very high-stress job
where people have to be performing at a
high level for the whole of the duration
of their shift and so if we can design
technology that I say with a sense when
people are becoming overloaded to stress
to perform at the level that they need
to we could give them that feedback so
for individuals that could be very
helpful for knowing when they need to
take a break I myself in a job you know
an average day it would be great if my
computer knew when I was in flow and
stopped interrupting me with email
notifications or if I needed to take a
break it could suggest things that would
help me relax and make me more
productive when I came back to my desk
and then I think it will also benefit
teams and organizations knowing the
well-being of your company is a really
important thing and we're starting to
see the development of really science
around organizations and in particularly
focused on the social components social
capital is really important and emotion
plays a big role in that tell me what
safeguards a designer or a developer
might think about so that this
technology doesn't become nanny-cam in
the workplace that's a really really
important question and I think as we
design this technology it's important
that we design social norms around how
they're used ultimately technology will
advance that's somewhat inevitable but
how we use technology in the social
norms that we design around it are not
inevitable so to give an example one of
the practices we follow is always opt-in
so we always make sure that people
choose to switch on sensors rather than
having
imposed upon them another example is as
we mentioned before allowing people to
turn off sensors and that's really
important people have that it increases
their trust and comfort with the system
a lot so there's a couple of examples
about its kind of social norms we can
design around this technology and I
think there are many more that will
develop as we kind of advanced
technology and think about use cases
[Music]
let's talk about reality for a bit
there's actual reality which I have a
passing familiarity with but also
virtual reality augmented reality mixed
reality there's so many realities give
us a baseline definition of each of
those different realities so we have a
frame of reference for what I want to
talk about next great so virtual reality
is a completely alternative environment
so this is where most people will
probably be familiar with virtual
reality in terms of the headsets with a
screen where all the information that
you see is displayed on that screen then
augmented reality is usually when you
can see the real world but there's some
augmentation of what you see so there
might be a transparent screen which is
actually displaying certain objects
which are superimposed on the real world
and then there's this idea of mixed
reality which is really blurring the
boundaries between virtual and augmented
reality so you are leveraging much
deeper understanding about the
environment as well as incorporating a
lot more augmentation so let's go along
that thread for a second here because
when you talk about augmenting human
perception through mixed or virtual
reality you suggest that VR might be
able to help people develop superhuman
senses so what are the possibilities and
challenges even of advancing human
senses in this way yeah so I mean one of
the things I find most fascinating about
other areas of science like neuroscience
is how adaptable we are and particularly
the brain
is at being able to learn new things
based on sensory input so we have a
panel at South by Southwest where we're
discussing some of the ways that sensor
inputs can influence people's perception
and one example that we've developed is
a system that allows people to look at
another individual and see physiological
responses of that person so it's data
they wouldn't normally be able to see
but it's superimposed onto that other
person so they can actually see their
heart beating they can see changes in
stress based on heart rate variability
and that's all sensed remotely but
you're giving the individual a new
sensory channel that they can leverage
something that they wouldn't normally
have so this is like x-ray vision in a
sense yes it's that's a I mean superhero
realm yeah exactly so that the idea of
super human senses would be
physiological senses that you wouldn't
normally be able to see it aside from
somebody's sweating or blushing or you
know their facial expressions it's
inside their bodies exactly yeah it's
hidden information that wouldn't
normally be accessible but using the new
technology like you know high-definition
cameras and this augmented experience
that we can create through the hololens
headset we can allow you to see that
information in real time so maybe now
junior high kids can actually find out
if someone's in love with them just by
putting on these glasses and they don't
have asked their friend to go ask their
other friend if he likes me
I've always wanted to build that demo
and just see how badly it fit was that
would actually be a really compelling
application of their technology just to
help the junior high kids so you're one
of the careers of an application of this
technology called cardio lens and while
it's still in the early stages of
research and it's not being used in any
real-life situations right now you're
actually able to read my heart rate by
looking at my face through a pair of
augment
reality glasses tell me more about this
what are the possibilities of this
research down the road yeah so I've been
working on this area of remote or
non-contact physiological measurement
for a while and this is the idea that a
regular webcam just the camera that
might be on your cell phone or on your
laptop has the sensitivity to pick up
very small changes in the color of your
skin or light reflected from your skin
to be more accurate which are related to
blood flow so actually by analyzing a
video input video stream to that camera
we can pick up your pulse we can pick up
your respiration rate and your heart
rate variability and this new work
showing you can measure blood
oxygenation and other things and people
are trying to get towards things like
blood pressure so just using a regular
device no adaptation to the hardware and
some software we can recover this
information so what we did was to put
the algorithm on the hololens which has
a camera that faces forward and so when
you look at someone it detects their
face it segments the skin it analyzes
the color change and recovers the
physiological information and then
displays that back in real time
superimposed onto their appearance how
accurate is it so the technology can be
very accurate so we've done a lot of
validation of this we can measure heart
rate to within one or two beats per
minute typically on a regular video
we're using deep learning to address
this problem and we've got really really
good results on some of the hardest
datasets that we've tried it on when you
take this out into the real world where
people are moving around and the
Lighting's changing and you can't
control if they're making facial
expressions or speaking or you know B
starts become more challenging but
that's the type of data that we're
pushing towards addressing so we want to
start designing methods that are robust
to all of those variations that we
actually see in a real life application
but normally you would measure someone's
blood pressure or their pulse in a
clinical setting I mean you wouldn't
necessarily which would be a tool maybe
for the medical community first
door yeah well the Junior High boy needs
exactly that might that might be the
biggest market no I think one
application I I am particularly excited
about is in medical applications for
instance surgery so you could see if a
particular part of the body has good or
poor blood flow and that could be
important in transplant operations where
you're attaching a new part of the body
a new organ and you need to know if
blood is flowing to that particular part
of the body and with a heads-up display
a surgeon could potentially look at that
region and see if there is a blood flow
signal but there are other applications
too another example would be for
instance being able to scan a scene and
identify if there's someone who's alive
for instance in a search and rescue
medication and this also works with
infrared cameras so even if it's dark we
can still measure the signal you know
there are other things like baby
monitors or in hospital ICU units
monitoring the physiological information
without having to have people wired up
it's a lots of different sensors we can
just use it camera to do that every
single show I end up shaking my head no
one can see it happening but it's like
really this is happening I can't believe
it it's amazing talk about the
trade-offs between the promises these
technologies make and some of the
concerns very real concerns about
privacy of the data yeah as I mentioned
before I think it's really important
that we design this technology
appropriately and I think that's where
we'll see the biggest benefits the
benefits are when people recognize this
is something that actually helps me in
my everyday life or helps in a specific
application like healthcare there are
definitely big challenges to privacy
because a lot of what we need to do to
deploy this technology is to be able to
sense information longitudinally on a
large scale because everyone experiences
emotion differently you can't just take
ten people and train a system on ten
people that will generalize to the whole
population and so
we do need to overcome that challenge if
you know how do we make this technology
such that people feel comfortable with
it they trust it and not lead them to
feel as though their privacy is violated
or that it's too obtrusive and so think
in design challenges it's about
designing ways for people to be aware
that technology's on that it's there
what it's measuring what it's doing with
that data and these are some more
unsolved problems as of yet you said you
prefer social norms over governmental
regulations or legal remedies so what's
the balance between the responsibilities
of scientists engineers or programmers
here versus big regulatory initiatives
like GDP are in Europe and other things
that might be coming down the pike I
think both are important but the reason
I prefer focusing on social norms is
because as a designer as an engineer
that's something I can actively
influence every day my job so I can
think about okay so I'm going to design
this sensor system that people are gonna
choose to use and capture their emotions
and it's gonna create an experience that
adapts to how they're feeling I can
choose how to design that and I can
influence the social norms around that
technology so being kind of a leader in
the research space allows me to do that
actively regularly and I don't think we
can necessarily rely 100% on government
or regulation to solve that piece of the
puzzle good part of being part of MSR is
that we're very involved with the
academic community I'm involved with the
future of computing academy at the ACM
and our task group within that
organization is to think about the
ethical questions around AI not just in
effective computing technology but just
broadly with machine learning and AI
technology that can make decisions about
important things like for instance
healthcare or justice and I think social
norms and governmental regulation both
serve a purpose there but one of the
things I personally can actively work
towards on a daily basis is thinking
through what do I ask people to give up
in terms of data
what do they get back for that and how
is that data used and that's something
I'm really really interested in let's
talk about you for a second I'm curious
how you got interested in the emotional
side of Technology and how you ended up
at MSR who were your influences through
inspirations your mentors so I did my
masters at Cambridge University and was
focused on machine learning but I was
very interested in how I could address
more social problems with that
technology not just focus on predicting
stock market prices or some of the sort
of numerical analyses that are often
solved using machine learning algorithms
I wanted to see how this technology can
help people and at the time my advisor
for my PhD Rosalind Picard who's one of
the founders of this field was working a
lot with applications for people on the
autism spectrum for whom
understanding emotions is a complex task
and often a big challenge in social
situations and that was one of the
reasons that I joined that lab is
because I really believed in the
potential benefits of effective
computing technology not just to one
portion of the population but to
everyone I could see how it could
benefit my life as well so that's how I
got into it and you know it's becoming
more true now but certainly 10 years ago
there was no technology you could really
think of that responded or understood
human emotion you know even now even now
I mean there yeah we're getting there in
research but there's not many real-life
applications you could point towards and
say oh this is an example of a system
that really understands non verbal or
emotional Keys right so was your path
from Cambridge and Rosalind Picard to
here sorry I went to the MIT Media Lab
where I took my PhD and there I worked a
lot on large-scale data analysis to do
with understanding emotions in
real-world contexts and then I worked
for a couple of years at startup and
joined MS
how of that and now lead the effects of
computing technology development within
research here that's really cool so as
we wrap up Daniel what thoughts or
advice would you leave with our
listeners many of whom are aspiring
researchers who might have an interest
in human-computer interaction or
effective computing what lines of
research are interesting right now what
my talk meant to use an industry term
the field if I were to summarize the
areas that I think are most important
the first would be multimodal
understanding so in the past a lot of
the systems that have been built have
focused just on one piece of information
like for instance facial expressions or
voice tone or text but to really
understand emotions you have to
integrate all that information together
because if I just look at facial
expressions you know if I were to show
you a video someone without the audio
and without the information about what
they were saying it would be hard to
interpret exactly how they felt or many
people have probably experienced being
on a phone call where they haven't been
able to exactly understand how someone
was feeling because you've only got the
voice tone and language to rely on you
don't have all of that visual
information about their gestures and
facial expressions and body posture so I
think multimodal understanding is really
important another area that I'm
particularly interested in is something
we've touched on already which is kind
of deploying this in the real world so
how do we take these experiments that
have typically been performed in labs in
research environments where he bring 10
or 20 people in and you get them to
experience a system and you evaluate it
which is fine for controlled studies but
ultimately if we're going to evaluate
the real system and how people will
actually respond to it in their everyday
lives we need to deploy it and so that's
something we're focused on is really
designing things that are so seamless
that people can use them without them
being a burden and we can start to mine
this data that occurs in everyday
contexts daniel McDuff it's been
fascinating talking to you I wish there
was more time but thanks
for coming in thank you very much
pleasure to be here to learn more about
dr. Daniel Macduff's work and find out
how machine learning can help you
improve your relationship with your
computer visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]